um my name is hans kim
um i'm in the van right now right next
to
downtown austin had a good time hooked
up to some restaurants wi-fi that i
ordered from earlier today
[Music]
just having a good old time enjoying
life
having a blast
hoping that this is working
but yeah i mean it's been a while since
i've been able to do this
i've been out on the road in the van
roughing it
trying to set forth new paths
that have not been
forged yet
so it's just
taken a while for me to find a stable
internet connection
so that i could do this and it's really
great to be back doing
another live
podcast by myself
this is like
so much fun for me
and it's very empowering because i don't
need anything or anyone else besides my
own wits and an internet connection
provided by some unwitting business or a
beautiful friend of mine
[Music]
i really enjoy being able to do this so
this is cool that i can do it again and
that i've been able to find a restaurant
with an amazing wi-fi connection that
goes all the way out into the street so
it's hard to do this
on a regular basis like i used to
um
so it's good that i'm able to do this i
just did five open mics tonight
um looks like you're having a blast lol
thanks man
this is my having a blast face can't you
tell how such a blast
hello from the south carolina
cheers from deutschland i farted
um so yeah i'm in this uh public
parking area it's like a diagonal
slanted uh
[ __ ] parking area where you can park
diagonally and then like there's people
next to me
it's thursday night it's 2 28 here in
austin texas i don't know what the [ __ ]
these people are doing but they're
yelling then there's homeless people
directly behind me
uh it's kind of a mess and that's where
i'm streaming from
hanza did my second stand up set last
night open mick but it went well you
inspired me to finally get up there
thanks man
for saying that i inspired you and
that's awesome that you did great
you are a beautiful human being and your
voice deserves to be heard and i'm glad
that you went out there and practiced
having a voice and making it a beautiful
one and one that's pleasant and not
so
unpleasant
um but yeah it's great
hans king can you do a show in ohio i'll
take all my friends
uh parentheses to close parentheses to
see you
i would love to go do a show in ohio
home of red band and tony
i did five mics tonight
uh
it's it was
great
the secret show was tonight i wasn't on
it um the secret show was amazing there
was uh
this other guy that went on there
i forget his name
but it was very alternative and very
funny
what's red band like in real life in
real life
he's like
uh really really um
he's like uh
he's like uh he's willing to listen to
you
uh and he's really nice and
uh one time i was talking to him and
then i said something that was awkward
or weird and then he was like okay hold
on and he like put us vape to his ear
and then he walked away and then he was
like this is this crazy thing you can do
you're an amazing comic dude keep up the
grind thanks for saying that thinking of
eyelid surgery yes i already told you
i'm thinking of this surgery
right here
i'm dreaming of this
hopefully i can be doing this
soon
once i get the surgery
but uh yeah um the grind is real i did
five open mics tonight
i did number one volstead with kat
strewbolt thank you for putting me up
early
open mike host and amazing comic cat
struble check her out on
the socials
number two
the thing that i did after that is
velveeta room an actual club amazing mic
actual audience
number three
hopefully there's no gunshots here
tonight because this is like a place
where there's a lot of gunshots
a lot of gang activity
is here
um number three was
tiniest bar
tiny little bar outside really
a lot of dudes a lot of open mic curves
there that was number three number four
roma room hosting the open mic and
having a good time
um
number five creek in the cave midnight
mike went up there for a bunch of comics
were sad and all the audience actually
left but i had a good time
i had to i have this new joke that i
think is pretty good
uh so you'll just have to wait and see
no this coming monday
kill tony comes out and it's one where
the guest is very
good and handsome and sexy and
funny and beautiful
and it's just like such a good time and
hopefully you like it
so that was fun
uh
i had the good sets
at certain places some good sets and
other places
i heard there's some [ __ ] going down
tonight
don't say that i'm so scared
my hair i uh
i'm showering a lot today a lot i
showered today i went to the gym
don't like my hair when i shower a lot
that's why i hate showering i refuse to
shower because i need beautiful hair
that beautiful shine on my hair
um
so i do want a gun i do want to stay
strapped
because that's an important part of my
life is being able to enact physical
violence whenever i feel like it
i think it'd be nice to do that
i just don't have a texas license plate
license
thing
so it's hard to get a gun in texas i
know it's so crazy you'd think that it's
texas you'd be able to buy a gun here
like that but it's not that easy
dude how do you get paid at kill tony
other than exposure 100 bucks
yeah actually five thousand bucks
hans i'm in the same parking lot as you
we neighbors
i don't think so darren wayne garter
because i didn't smell your fart
uh what music do i like
i like
indian alternative and bluegrass
[Music]
so yeah
i can
do martial arts but i think the best
martial art is running away or
being a really nice person that nobody
wants to hurt
uh it's tricky in a van because people
might murder me
with a stray bullet but you know it's a
risk i'm willing to take i'm guessing
that there aren't that many stray
bullets around here
the thing i like about this is that i'm
not just on the street like only my ass
end is out on the street which is where
my head goes when i sleep but you know
you got to take some risks at least it's
not like i can't get broadsided as
easily here
um
so yeah i mean what else is going on
there's so much going on um
i um
sometimes i'm really depressed and stuff
because i'm only thinking about myself
in the way that the worst people see me
that hate me the most
because those are the ones that uh make
the biggest impact on your life because
they're like
negative and it's like oh [ __ ]
it's just more interesting to think
about negative people than positive
people in my life like there's a hundred
thousand positive and then one negative
person that i focus on
but uh you know it's just crazy because
it's not really like a big deal because
those people are
not should not define me
and i hope that they don't and i don't
think that they do but
yeah i'm just trying to have a good time
and uh you know like do i really need to
[ __ ] someone all the time
sex is so overrated i don't even like
sex anymore
i just thought myself out of sex and
it's like no i don't have to do that
anymore and it's like oh wow
it's like do girls or are they even like
worth changing myself for
or should i just like be like a happier
version of the person that i am and then
i'll get laid more or whatever
um
but who cares
uh it's good that i'm alone so that i
can do this
podcast
or live
don't think too much about all that i
agree
yeah i mean i'm uh i guess i'm lonely
and so like i'm sad because i'm lonely
but it's like i don't really care
uh i shouldn't take myself in my
emotions that seriously but alex jones
alex jones is very nice to me
uh i saw alex jones in the green room
when i walked in for when i was opening
up for joe rogan last tuesday and he was
like this
this guy's a funny guy
this guy's a funny guy
this guy's around the guy
so he said i was funny and uh it's alex
jones saying that and i don't know why
he thinks that or what he's basing that
on but i'll take his word for it if he
thinks so it must be
true
um you have stage one gay
i wish
maybe if i got [ __ ] in the butt i'd be
really really happy um yeah so
life's been crazy i've been watching
succession at tony's suggestion a
succession suggestion
and i've been really enjoying it even
though it's just people talking and
yelling at each other it's still fun in
some ways
um
i'm gonna look at danny quigley's
facebook story
oh my god the internet here is so good
oh danny quigley is back at the crc
uh which is in georgia tech
and it's where i spent a lot of time
playing basketball
and uh they got like six quarts they're
separated by like this mesh
and the the games there would be crazy
it's just like
a bunch of uh
you know african-americans that are tall
and big and then like five
two white people and it's just like so
so much uh
competition and it's just so good that's
why i mentioned the races uh because
it's atlanta and it's like real
basketball and like people who are
actually good but then if you're really
good it's like what are you even doing
here like
you're you're like a in college
on a college team like why are you
playing with a bunch of scrubs so it's
like there's a ceiling to that but it's
like pretty competitive and like people
really
like it's so crazy because people are
like everything's ruled by money but you
then you go to the crc and watch people
play basketball and they they get paid
nothing they're doing it for free and
it's just fun they're doing it for the
glory so for the reputation so that when
people see them they're like oh it's
this guy coming up and that's all we
need all we need is each other's
approval and that really set me up for
open mics it's the same sort of vibe
um
it's like we're not doing it for the
money we're doing it because we love to
do it and this is such a naturally
inherently interesting
competitive thing that we like to do
where we like to compete with each other
so it's really cool
uh getting those internet routers that
some van lifers have i would love to
i'm saying big black dudes
um heaven is your own son
i have not been to joe rogan's home if i
went to joe rogan's home i would just be
bowing and being respectful and just
trying to keep my arms in so that i
don't have like a moment in pirates of
the caribbean where he breaks the
chandelier
so i just try to be really really nice
you email georgia to get on tiger belly
why would i
would i be like a guest on there like
calling in through zoom
because
unless i'm going to go there in person
and they have like big guests on there
so it's not like i could compete with
them
so i don't feel like i'm worthy enough
to get on tiger belly yet
but maybe maybe in the future that's a
great suggestion i'd love to do it
what's the most you've ever lost in a
coin toss
i did a coin toss to see if i quit my
job at quiznos when i was working there
in high school and
the coin flipped to quit my job and it's
just like why would i drew do this job
for the experience because the money is
like good but it's like i'm in high
school i don't really need it
uh
um
yeah i mean it's just so crazy out there
um
so everyone every time i do a podcast or
do anything people are like you're high
you're high you're high i'm not high i
wish i was high
uh i didn't smoke at all didn't drink at
all today
i'm trying not to smoke because i have a
really sensitive throat but yeah i
haven't done any drugs it's not like i
wouldn't
i would if i could um i'm
i'd love to do drugs drugs are a great
way to feel happy
um it helps in your mind did you hear
that
i think that's a homeless it reminds me
how to be happy so that's important um
so yeah i mean i would love to do drugs
this stream is brought to you by this
restaurant that i'm in front of thank
you for the wi-fi
i went in there ordered some food and
then i took their wi-fi um and now i get
to park in front of their house in front
of the restaurant when they're closed
their wi-fi is still on and i am
streaming hopefully they don't check
their logs and are like why is it
spiking in the middle of the night we
should not give our name a pass right
out
how many push-ups can i do i can do
probably like 30 maybe 40 if i really
try
um but yeah i've been working out
hopefully
you can tell my arm i'm really insecure
about how thin my arms are
um
but yeah i've been working out so i just
try to be uh be more strong
i think it's good to be strong
i think it helps my neck i have a neck
injury
um but yeah
um i'm enjoying life i'm doing a lot of
things and
i'm doing whatever i do
um
you're in your van yes i'm in my van i
would show you outside but i'm afraid
that there's gonna be a homeless person
looking in
oh yeah
there's someone there
um so yeah it's crazy because it's just
like
right
there's like people
right outside and they don't realize
that i'm in another universe right now
talking to the internet
and they're just out there being
homeless and stiff
uh
have you seen why are you insecure about
your arms have you seen the size of your
head
man yeah the bigger the head the smaller
the arms i don't have to have big arms i
can just ram my head into people
um cops ever bother you in your van not
yet i have never been bothered by a
copper rooney in the van i've been
pulled over in the van for being high
uh i went to this uh dune buggy place
imperial mountain in california or
something and then i went to the aid
station i was like is there anywhere to
camp here that's like not so like crazy
there's a bunch of white people being
like trump supporters there and like
gathering their rvs up and like they
have like their own village there and
it's they're dune bugging all over the
place it's not like a pleasant place to
camp because everyone has their atvs
and utvs and it's like dusty and it's
like yeah i mean why would you
go out into the middle of nowhere and
then just hang out with a bunch of other
people it's like the city like you just
you can't drove out all this way to be
with other people
anyways so then i asked them is there
anywhere else to camp and then they were
like yeah over here and then i was like
oh thank you sorry i'm so awkward i'm
really hurt right now and then i drove
away and then those medics in the medic
tent that i just asked that question to
told the cop and the cop was
like ah a guy said he was high and he's
driving let me go chase him down and
then he like you said you're high you
can't be hiding you're a bad person for
being high and driving even though i
know everyone does it and i'm in
california you're technically on federal
land so i can be a dick to you
even though the people of california
voted that this isn't a big deal and
they want to live in a state with
marijuana i'm still going to be a dick
because it's a rule and i get to enforce
whatever role i want
and i get to do a culture war on you uh
so yeah and then uh he was he was just
like you can't drive back home call your
friend tell him to come pick you up i
was like okay fine don't do that
uh
i was like have you read the studies on
the marijuana effects on driving and
he's like i don't have to read
that study but then i just decided to
take that part where he just said i
don't have to read and i was like yeah
because you're a dummy
uh and he's like what are bothering me
um
so
yeah and then he was like you can't
drive and then he's like okay i'll call
my friend and then he drove away and
then i was just drove in my van and
drove off and it was like waste of like
an hour and a
half um
so yeah that's the only time a cop
bothered me in the van um
it's like why shouldn't i be allowed to
live in my van if i if i want to live in
my van it's like
i'm the i'm only hurting myself and
isn't this the land of the free like i
have to live in a certain way in a
certain house and pay a certain amount
of money
in the land of the free like shouldn't i
be able to be like a pioneer and
hitch my wagon and
leave and be crazy and do whatever i
want like that's what america was built
on i have to have a house you have to
have an address we can come find you and
[ __ ] with you right
um
yeah i'm a step ahead when the
apocalypse hits so it's like crazy
yeah i attended college i even graduated
a college called georgia institute of
technology with a degree in mechanical
engineering bachelor of science and it's
i'm not using it
and i think it's uh great to do so that
i can be like hey look i'm smart like
see i don't have any insecurities i
could have been like you i just chose
not to so that's the only thing my
college degree is good for us not making
me intellectually insecure around other
smart people
or smart people i don't want to say that
i'm sorry what do you think of asian
girls that dye their hair blonde i think
they're hot and sexually attractive and
i want to stick my dick deep inside
their vaginas
idk if that's what america was built on
but i hear you brother
well america was definitely not built on
uh
people living in their vans but america
was built on people
traveling west in wagons you know it's
like i don't need to live in a house
like why should we enforce house-ness on
everyone
uh what's five times fourteen is seventy
yep i'm right
should i make my kids go to
college that's such a tricky question
on one hand if they make them go to
college then they're set up for the
world and they're set up for the way
things exist right now and then they
have a head start in some ways but on
the other hand like everyone has a
college degree and like they're not even
set up for like a job like if you really
want to set them up with a job
give just give them a hundred grand
and be like here's a hundred grand that
i would have given you for college take
this and live your life and try to do
something crazy
and that would be probably a better time
than going into this
rote memorization school where you're
just gonna do everything like everyone
else does it like do you want your kids
to be like everyone else or do you want
them to be awesome
i would say
give them a van and let them live their
life in a van
or something
um
i don't know college college college
uh you should do whatever that is best
for that kid if your kid is sort of like
a bookworm and he doesn't really think
outside the box and he's good at like
sitting in a cubicle and farting on
command in the bathroom during breaks
then get him into college but if your
kid is like a free spirit and he's
suffering and uh
this uh
shitty system that we have where we make
children sit still for six hours then
get them out of the van or get them out
of the college put them into somewhere
awesome
know any good
mechanics
dude living in a van i used to live in a
minivan before this i i used to live
around mechanics and just indulge in
their lifestyle and it's like a really
crazy place
um
yeah i mean if you do crypto and you
live in a house good for you
it's cool that you can do something like
that and i have a life but uh for me
like i don't want to do crypto
and uh so i don't and i live in a van so
i can do comedy like if i do comedy a
lot maybe i could live in a house
eventually but
at the moment i couldn't have done that
so then i did this
and um
i uh
i really enjoyed the opportunities that
i got from this
and uh
i think a homeless guy is yelling
outside
um but yeah i mean not everyone can uh
do that
uh definitely piss in the bottle
way off the road bub
way of the road bub but here's the thing
if you piss in your bottle and you drink
it then your kidneys have to do more
work and your kidneys are going to get
[ __ ] up if you drink too much piss
um yeah kindergarten you pulled your
hair out when you were in kindergarten
[ __ ] was stressful for some reason i
wonder why we take you away from your
parents and surround you with strangers
and then we're like you're safe here
believe me or else it's not a natural
way we just industrialized education and
made us into little cogs and factory
little
widgets and that's not what humans are
we have no we don't have a clear
conception of how to take care of humans
and be
nice to them and we don't know how to
[ __ ] help and nurture humans because
we don't know what humans are we are
uh
we're just treating humans badly because
we don't know ourselves
[Music]
so
i
it's weird because if i don't hold on to
this it starts buzzing
um
when you come into houston i'm coming to
houston january like 9th or something
or 11th through 12th i'm headlining a
show at the secret group so
let me know if you want to go hans
what's your women weight limit
there's some fat girls that can
contain it well and they still look
beautiful but if i'm going to be with
them long term my weight limit's
probably like 150
max
i'm 165 so if they're 150
i can still
have 15 pounds above them
i'm still a weight class above them
which is important
because people like
to be dominated sometimes
and
what are my thoughts on travis scott
i think that
he ran a very poor festival he didn't
organize it properly he didn't think
about what he was doing he just sort of
did it and it was a mess and it killed
people and he needs to be more competent
i talked to this girl who says that she
used to be classmates with travis scott
and he was always making beats and
having meetings in a cafe in a cafe and
a mall
[Music]
and stuff like that and he wasn't that
cool and now he's cool so whatever
um
i'm in the van
you look like you're torturing yourself
okay um what will it take to move into a
house steady income
a paycheck
that gives me at least a thousand bucks
every month
um
i open for rogan and that gives me a lot
so if i could open for rogan three times
uh
times two
so six times a month then i could move
in the house
but that's so unreliable like i can't
rely on it like until i can actually
rely on it and have like a steady income
that i'm not going to do it because i
can do everything i want in this van and
plus it lets me be out more i'm always
out because there's no home for me to go
to oh
um
uh
yeah my eyes are open i just
maybe if i hold it up here
then it'll be like um
my eyes are open but i don't know should
i open my eyes artificially so that it i
don't look so [ __ ] weird
um
i would tell you how much rogan pays me
but
now he doesn't pay me 160 for opening
for him
uh
eyes are overrated that's true i barely
have any and i'm a regular on kill tony
hey man what was hitler like
and then his friend tanis omg are the
best right yeah that's the yellows
i like stormy
so i like yellow rose
um but yeah i mean why did i go to texas
i went i came here to texas because i
was longing for an adventure i had
already been in los angeles i already
knew what that city held for me and what
that ladder looked like but austin texas
was a new adventure there was
gold to be found there was
uh
strange
ladders to climb and it's just different
and it's just
a fun thing you know
so i decided to go there
how long until hans kim realizes
he's getting played by the comedians
opens for yeah i'm getting played by joe
rogan if joe rogan wants to play me
please play me i would be i'd be honored
to be played by joe rogan and i'm not
i'm getting a lot of money
um
the strange ladder i climbed is the
ladder of austin open mics and comedy
i mean even before i did the kill tony
thing i was like
known in the scene and i was just happy
to be here and hopefully i can keep
being happy to see people and being
happy to be in the scene
and talk to people
writing new material yeah i wrote today
about uh
how
fix the audio on your dating show bro
okay so the dating show
uh the last two weeks there was no audio
guy raymond
uh
is his name he was supposed to be there
5 30 showed up at like after the show
started so the audio was [ __ ]
and then the second time he he just quit
he didn't show up so don't blame me
blame the [ __ ] audio guy he's
supposed to show up and do his [ __ ]
job but he decided to [ __ ] not do it
you [ __ ] idiot show up the show is
relying on you this guy
this guy he just
didn't show up
but hey uh the good thing is that the
product still was there uh to me i
didn't know the audio was that shitty
while it was happening so uh i'm not
gonna change it like uh
for me i just went through the paces so
i'm learning i'm getting better and now
with with the audio fixed hopefully the
show will be good
and i'll have practiced doing the show
so hopefully it'll be it'll be fine
if i lived in austin i would have done
it for free damn
red button smells like ketchup and mayo
red ban is not smelly he's a very clean
man who lives in a house
em wahlberg great quote
i'm the guy that does his job you must
be the other guy
uh hey do you hang out with redband's
korean girlfriend
um
do i hang out with robin's korean
girlfriend i mean i hang out with
redband and his korean girlfriend who's
a very nice lady
um
i uh i hang out with a lot of people
um but yeah i mean we
we know each other we we're nice and to
each other and he's like a
he's like a nice she's like a nice
person and uh she's like really nice and
then we hang out and she's really really
nice and i really respect
respect her
oh my god
i think i saw a ghost
that's william montgomery ghost hunting
um
i think that uh
it's great that uh
we get to do all this stuff
um
i'm korean
um
i really
really enjoy
the kill tony experience
i think it's really cool and uh really
fun
i touched william william always touches
me he like scratches my chest with one
finger he always goes like that on my
chest
um
shouts out from norway
how do you shower in a van in a gym i
have a gym membership now um
and it's so [ __ ] awesome
because
the gym i've been working out i've been
working out like
multiple days now and i hope that i can
continue it and it's just great because
um the gym helps me feel better
physically and i do a little rehab and
i get stronger
and hopefully i can fix my neck
um
yeah i mean uh
squid games was a great show
uh squid games was fun i enjoyed it i
think the best thing about squid game is
the
friendship
and the camaraderie
that's
uh
how you survive in a survival situation
it's not how many guns you have or how
many how many cans of spam it's how well
do you work with others
and uh the friendships and the romances
that
you do
when you are
in a situation like that
um
and i think like a lot of relationships
are not that practical a lot of
relationships are like
a distraction from life and then when
you actually have to do something it's a
different thing entirely
um
so i uh
sorry
i um
yeah i mean it helps to have friends
with guns uh guns help um
how do you delineate between material
for kill attorney versus using it for a
normal show
i
just make an educated guess like i think
this will work i'll kill tony okay here
we go
and it's always always successful
and i hope you guys
don't hate the next episode
um but yeah i mean i love doing this
kill tony i
i feel like i need to do better i feel
like uh i want to kill soon
um
yeah i always worry about running out of
material for kill tony i i want to do
better i want to do good i want to be a
good comedian so
that's just
that's just my life
um
yeah i don't know
i don't know
uh i am not that short i'm 5 11.
i would love to be friends with eddie
bravo he can show me how to wrap my legs
around somebody and make them fall in
love with me
uh he's still saving the scissor joke
for next kt i did this kt i did the
scissor joke already it's on the record
so
why am i melting i don't know am i
melting
uh so yeah i mean my life is going
pretty good
um i'll tell you i think he's a little
bit shorter than me
why am i awake i slept a lot um recently
and uh now i'm awake
i uh i get lonely at night yes i do and
it's very very sad and i'm so sad that a
boy
um no i mean i'm fine
uh
i uh
i'm not that short
um
i
i think that uh height is pretty cool
i mean if you're taller you're gonna not
live as long but while you're alive
you're gonna be more awesome
um and if you're short you're going to
live a long time
uh and you can watch all your tall
friends die
so that's pretty cool
chris m asked so is this live so is this
live yeah it's live um any material on
jazlane maxwell
not really i mean
i don't really know much about the
situation it's like why what's the deal
with her she's just like some dude that
got
little girls for
people to [ __ ]
um
um
so how do you get yourself to practice
your craft when you're not in the mood
um i uh it's just a habit like it's for
me i've been doing it nine almost nine
years now so it's just like whenever you
know
i'm bored it's like oh is there a mic
tonight let's go do a mic tonight and
then it's like i don't even have to
think about it i just [ __ ] do it
because uh it's like it's just my life
like you don't have to think about like
do i want to go to work today you just
go to work that's just uh what you do
and that's for me comedy is that and
it's like even if i don't feel like it i
never realize it because i'm already on
my way to a mic and i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm
gonna be on stage in five
hours let me think of something oh [ __ ]
what if i said this what if i said that
and then it's like i don't have to think
about whether i want to do it or not i
don't i don't listen to myself i uh
ignore my wants and desires like it's a
little kid in the back seat crying
i don't want to go out i'm scared and
when i'm playing don't do it he's like
shut up we're going we're on the road
already we're so it's just a habit like
it's like i'm i'm out i'm doing it and
it's fun it's fun as [ __ ] to be out
there like even if the comedy's not fun
hanging out with people is fun and even
if hanging out with people isn't fun
hanging out with your people is fun and
even if hanging out with your friends
isn't fun hanging out with like other
comedians who are successful is fun so
you can like talk to them and be like
hey
i'm uh
this comedian and you're that comedian
and we're forging together our brands
right now what a great experience we're
having
uh so yeah it's just so [ __ ] awesome
uh
i don't think
stephanie tanner isn't she from full
house
um so what do you think of shane gillis
i think shane is so [ __ ] funny and
he's only been doing comedy like nine
years or something he's like a one
wunderkind he's very funny um he thinks
chinese people in chinatown are
disgusting or something and it's like
yeah that's that's what they look like
like
they're not acting like normal they're
not like
doing their best to appear normal
they're like in chinatown doing crazy
[ __ ] not giving a [ __ ] just living their
life like they're back in
the sichuan province
so yeah people are going to think you're
weird because you did absolutely no work
to make people at ease and feel
comfortable so yeah people are gonna be
weirded out at chinatown like they know
that they uh they do that on purpose so
yeah people are gonna talk [ __ ] about
chinatown so uh
why don't you just relax on
the shingles asian whatever
you smoke of the ganjans yes i smoke of
the guns i love the kanji where
is my ganja
um
are in the glass it's just a prop
nope i need them to see
um i love my glasses sometimes i wish i
didn't wear them because it's just like
a thing on my face
i don't like having [ __ ] on my face
but then i got used to it so it's like
also it creates little indents in my
nose just like all that constant
pressure
and i wonder if it
prevents me from breathing properly but
ideally i would go no glasses i think i
look better without glasses
i think with glasses i look like there's
something on my face
and i i want to go no glasses more
i don't wear glasses on this because i
wear these headphones so that i can hear
myself and really be in the zone uh and
with glasses on it's just
annoying because they're like sticking
out right here and it's just [ __ ]
painful in my ear sometimes try
binoculars
try just wearing binoculars all the time
so you can see things really really far
away
um
yeah i mean i don't always need eye
protection from rocks being thrown at my
eyes i just tend to avoid anywhere that
has rocks being projected over long
distances
um ever experienced racism in texas uh i
mean the city is designed this whole
state is designed
for racism i mean
but i haven't really experienced it just
more like general
um
oh you're not whiteness whenever i go to
like a bar in like deep texas it's like
you went from around here are you but
then they see so many minorities they
can't be doing that to everyone so it's
like there's a healthy balance
of
overt versus covert racism but also
sometimes it's not really racism they're
just like uh wary of outsiders no matter
if they're white
or not but if you're not it's just more
apparent
hey bro you like dragons
your eyes look close without them no
joke
yes i do not care i want to not wear
glasses because they hurt my face
um
i saw your video
yeah
thanks man
uh
are you in your van
[Music]
texas is designed for racism because of
suburban sprawl white flight and
uh
because
the downtown area is like
uh they have like a
[ __ ]
highway right in the middle of it
do you feel people judging you when you
eat a hot dog
can i send you a t-shirt sure
send it to the vulcan
go into smoke with wish me luck sweet
korean prince
going to smoke
wish you luck what's gonna happen
if you're unlucky when you smoke
um
i uh
uh
okay so
what do you guys think about the
general
theory of relativity
i've never gotten a nasty throat
infection from the strippers
um i haven't kissed a stripper in a
while now
i need to refill my stripper
whatever
uh my stripper
stripper tank
um
how do you know a joke will do better
than another joke isn't that entirely
trial and error based
yeah it is a lot of trial and error and
also how you feel about it uh if you
like enjoy saying it then you're going
to say it more and then if you get a lot
of positive reactions you're going to
enjoy saying it more and if you get a
lot of negative reactions you're going
to be like huh for some reason i don't
feel like saying this joke right now i
don't know why but let me try it anyways
oh
that was why
death desolation smog
dragon oh fire
uh do you do your kt material for the
first time on stage or do you work it
out during this week usually i work it
out during the week but one time i
didn't do that and i don't know it went
all right i wish i wish that i had more
time to perfect the bits
sometimes so i try not to do it right
away i try to let the joke breathe
and give myself some time to do it
because otherwise it's not that good
[Music]
do you prefer short talks with friends
or long deep conversations
i prefer long deep conversations i hate
it when people say so how's your day
been
that's a sign that the conversation is
dead
uh there's always something to talk
about like uh where we are what we're
doing who's there what how they're doing
it why they're doing that that way and
if you don't like being in the moment
and you always constantly need to escape
and talk about some [ __ ]
then i don't want to talk about that i
want to talk about the here and now and
how to best escape the situation in case
a
shooter comes in or whatever um
is there anything more interesting than
comedy right now yeah tragedy uh
drama
horror
right now succession is really
interesting to me i don't really
um
yeah i talk to christy vera sometimes i
occasionally talk to her i just
don't want to talk to her too much
because it's like
i don't want to get too invested with
people that don't want to have sex with
me it's like
um
[Music]
i'm just gonna get frustrated i'm just
gonna be horny i'm just gonna like
constantly ask you to [ __ ] me so i'm
i'll just not like i'll just not talk to
you so that i don't become [ __ ]
sad and
rapey you know so it's just like what if
you don't want to [ __ ] me like i don't
understand that like why wouldn't you
want to [ __ ] me i'm so [ __ ] hot but
also it's like if you don't want to do
this awesome thing like
like i ideally i'd be having sex with
everyone that i'm close with um
excluding guys but it's like even if i
if i was bi that'd be ideal you know
like if i could just have sex with
everyone and then i could feel awesome
all the time it's like
i don't understand this like need to not
have sex with people so it's like i try
to avoid
people that don't want to have sex with
me because it makes me feel bad it makes
me be like why why are you doing that
why are you not having sex with me
because like
even if i sort of liked a girl and you
know
it'd just be nice and pleasurable to
make each other come
yeah i stay up late it's like a comedy
thing
i uh
i stay up late i do comedy open mics i
do comedy shows till 2am
um
[Music]
you know you must
have a bad relationship with your mom
then
well i think that there are certain
people that you don't have sex with uh
like your family
but uh if you're not your family and
you're not having sex then why why don't
you have sex with people that
you're not uh whatever
women are turned off by feeling sexually
objectified well they should
fix that because
um because like uh
if someone wants to have sex with me i'm
not uh
all [ __ ] up by it i'm not like oh you
just see me as an object sometimes
you're an object sometimes you're in
line at starbucks and you're just an
object i'm not like how dare you
objectify me i'm not just an object i'm
a human being with thoughts and emotions
they'd be like [ __ ] you right now to me
you're an object you're standing in line
and you're not moving
move you're an object be an object that
moves
um being an object is like such a
such a reductive way to look at sex oh
you just think that i'm an object i
don't have sex with objects you're a
human being and right now i'm
emphasizing your sexual parts
um
that doesn't mean that i don't respect
you
in fact a lot of people that i respect i
want to have sex with so
i'm actually respecting you just because
they want to have sex with you doesn't
mean i think you're a terrible person or
i don't know what that means why why do
you think that sex is a bad thing i
think there's just some puritan [ __ ]
um but uh yeah you want to be a special
object i would love to be a special
object
um yeah i mean i
i try to chill and connect with them in
a real way
uh
so
uh
did you have a favorite subject in high
school my favorite subject in high
school was probably a band or something
i love being
doing stuff like that
[Music]
uh
i uh
you can send me a flashlight i love to
have sex with the flashlight i mean i
said i don't have sex with objects but
i feel like
a fleshlight is a great object to have
sex with
um i would love to be on william's
podcast if he will have me i would love
to do it i love math too math is so cool
i used to play trumpet in the band uh
um
i loved the freeform nature of it i
loved that it was art i loved that there
were friends that we i was just goof off
i was such a [ __ ] menacing band i was
just being crazy
um
it's just water
do you have a weapon in your van in case
someone tries to carjack you i have a
spear
uh it's a very beautiful spear let me
pull it out to see how ready i am
someone's talking
is someone trying to stream snipe me
or is someone about to get shot
if i if i get shot at least it'll be
live streamed
someone record this
so this is my spear
this is how ready i am for action
i got this because i was camping in the
woods in the in the in the desert
um
so you just pop it open
and now you have a spear
and now you can stab people
from far away
oh yeah yeah
and this is good because
a gun takes fine motor movements
and in a panic situation it's hard to
like just move your finger
uh it's very unnatural but in a panic
situation you have a spirit like ah
this is more natural
so i'm i don't need that much oops i
don't need i just stab my window i don't
need that much training with this it's
really hard to train with this i look
like a [ __ ] idiot
just waving my spear around it's just
pretty pretty so it's pretty intuitive
just gotta wait until they get close and
you just gotta go hey yeah stay back
stay back
stay back stay back
and then i have like a homemade spirit
that i made from like this metal
but yeah i mean this is mostly for
animals with humans i don't really want
to use a spear because they might have a
gun
uh yeah i'm not high i'm not high at all
i'm sober as [ __ ] i've never done this
high and which is crazy because usually
i get high a lot i'm taking off my pants
um part
of the body
would you aim for price center mass
uh you know anything that you hit is
good
i mean i would just use two hands
a lot of people are running around
hopping in cars right now
but drugs usually on one weed i always
try to bring a spirit to a gunfight
um
i don't know why people are saying i'm
melting
i guess we're all melting
into the earth
yeah i mean if i really want to [ __ ]
if i really want to meet people
really look into their eyes as i murder
them
um are you in your van right now bro yes
bro i'm in my van right now
this is the van
uh do you believe in ghost paranormal
stuff
no
i don't i uh i haven't
i haven't uh
i haven't uh believed in ghosts and
paranormal stuff and it really hasn't
affected my life at all
like
i think that uh if ghosts are real and i
can not believe in them and then my life
doesn't change like what's the point of
ghosts like it doesn't do anything even
if you believe in them
i should start whacking it i don't think
that i can monetize that and uh
hopefully you know i can make money off
of this
uh
so yeah has anyone tried breaking into
your car while you were inside it
no not really my friend did that had
that happen to him once
and he got into a fight
it's like
he's he tried tested his doors but i say
just let him if they're doing that just
let him [ __ ] test the doors after
this
i'm probably gonna move to a different
place i'm gonna go to a park without
wi-fi
just so i can chillax
um
but yeah i mean if i start whacking off
i definitely can't monetize it so i'm
definitely not going to start just
jerking it right now
um
where are the bitties at i don't know if
that's some internet reference or if
that means [ __ ] but there are no
[ __ ] here right now
so so very sad i feel like uh
i need to be happier i need to be a more
reliable source of happiness for girls
and then they'll be like oh i like him
he's so happy and fun whenever i hang
out with him he's always fun so let me
be hanging in with him because it'll be
fun i'd rather hang out with him because
it's fun he's always going to be fun and
this other guy he's not as fun so why
would i want to hang out with him when i
know for sure i can have so much fun
with the other guy and that's fun
so it's like almost like
impossible because then it's like if if
you're fun then there's no reason for
them to not hang out with you so it's
like you just gotta be a positive impact
in people's life
and uh sometimes i don't try to be a
positive
thing i just
do whatever the [ __ ] i want and
what would you do though that's so dumb
were you doing that that's stupid you
shouldn't do that
and instead i should just be like
oh
that's so cool
whoa
that looks like a little penguin in an
upside down
human pyramid
or just thinking like crazy [ __ ] and
just
just be like i'm not logical but hey at
least it's fun
but you have to be somewhat logical or
else the fun has no context and it's
just
not as fun
i feel bad for asian men women are
openly racist to asian men i'm not gonna
lie not sure why it's accepted in 2021
you know why
women are openly racist to asian men
it's because we are effeminate and
uh
not as sexy as black men
uh and that's just the way it is you
know some people
are
tall and handsome other people are short
and
weak and uh
it's like uh you know it's just you know
it's just like what are you gonna do
you're gonna force them to find asian
men attractive or just be like hey
that's just
asian men are not attractive
just deal with that just deal with being
unattractive i don't want to be
attractive i've seen attractive people
and they're very attractive but i don't
want to live their life i think their
lives are empty and meaningless and
pointless and they're just meat bodies
that are going to decay in 80 to 70
years and
they're gonna die and no one's gonna
give a [ __ ] because they were just a
[ __ ] meat body
i want to be something more than this
this flush i want to [ __ ] extend my
consciousness beyond this realm
some asian women only date asian men and
asian women are some of the most
attractive
that's true but we have a home field
advantage hans you need to travel to
brazil heaven for asian men
the girls stared at me
all over sao paulo they stared at you i
feel like i need something more than
just stairs
but uh yeah i mean we have a home field
advantage we grow up with them the asian
women the hottest women in the world
they have
asian men as father figures and then
they try to [ __ ] their fathers later so
like we do get that benefit so it's like
it's not that bad because at least as an
asian man you get to [ __ ] asian women
slightly easier
but uh yeah
i love asian women and i love boning
them even though they have no asses
do you think asian trans women look
better than black trans
well if you go to thailand or whatever
place where they are they're all doing
that then yes they have perfected
looking like women
uh i hate to break it to you but there's
attractive people of substance lol
yeah
not that many a lot more ugly people who
are killing it
um and i'm proud to be an ugly because
our people have extended our
consciousness all throughout the world
lincoln gandhi
others
um black i i'm not really that familiar
with the trans of different races i uh
i'm not a chaser i don't look for that i
don't mind if you do i have a friend
who's chaser
and uh
it's very interesting that he's like
that it's cool
hans women love bts you should put on
makeup and dye your hair and look like a
bts group member
you think my goofy ass head would fit in
a bts
band
if that bts were all lined up and then i
was there
i would look at a place
my head is too big
no one wants a big-headed man
are you not trends
um so yeah i mean uh
trans-racial people are coping in a
variable you are not ugly hans in fact
you're you have beautiful hands
thanks jesse
uh showing your spotify wrapped here's
the funny thing i don't have spotify
because i refuse to pay for music i grew
up in the 90s and 2000s
i grew up where music was free and i
refused to go backwards from that
i know that everyone else has welcomed
the corporatization of the internet with
open arms like look
i can go on facebook and i can talk to
all my friends this isn't convenient i'm
not going to think about the downsides
of this but i remember an internet that
was free that was
maddox and gorilla page and tucker max i
remember the internet when it was just
people talking to people and not a
corporation controlling what you see and
controlling your friends list so they
can sell you more ads
and i long for that world again and i
believe that we can reach it again we
just need to
uh
banish
spotify back to where they came from go
back to sweden you [ __ ]
um
i i go on youtube and i get all my music
from youtube which is still a
corporation but what are you gonna do
they monopolized videos
and then i got youtube advanced
it's like advanced without the ad i
don't know if this will demonetize me
but
that will
take away the ads so now i have no ads i
have music i make a playlist i just play
it from there so unfortunately i don't
have a spotify wrapped i wish i did i
wish uh i could you know figure out that
out but you know
that's what i get for not having to pay
120 a year
that's not worth it
i don't want to pay 120 dollars to know
what music i listen to i already know
what music i listen to i listen to the
greatest showman soundtrack amazing
soundtrack i listen to
uh
i'm going to show you right now
um
others other things that are awesome
oh it's just so awesome my music i'm
actually really tired of my music i
listen to a lot of b miller
i listen to cam
this is a lot of nickel creek i listen
to a lot of ingrid michaelson i love
phineas that's pretty much my [ __ ] man
do i pay for netflix no i actually get
netflix from my family i get disney plus
from a friend
i got i don't have hbo anymore because
they switched from hp hbo max or hbo go
to hbo max and i had an hbo go with my
friend grant that i met on the subway in
new york
i miss new york i love new york new york
is a great place
uh it's just wasn't right for me because
they don't give a [ __ ] about me
you only pay five bucks for spotify
that's if you're a student
um unless they cheapen the price
uh
but yeah uh
uh yeah i thought it was 10 bucks a
month
for spotify
uh not everyone's a student and i don't
have a student account anymore i used to
do my sister's student account i used to
pay for spotify like a chump
like a 2021 loser
um
bruce hornsby
uh
five year maybe it's five bucks now i
don't know i don't keep up with it
because i pay zero i'd rather play pay
zero than
five
in terms of math
okay they church five dollars i was
wrong i'm a very bad bad person
um
so nyc i used to live in nyc for three
years i was a new york city rat a comedy
rat i was doing comedy all over the city
doing seven mics a day
being a [ __ ] hustler
uh so i'm really enjoying comedy right
now or it's
you know a smaller city but i get more
exposure
it's four o'clock in the morning
conversation got boring
damn such a beautiful voice
uh it's actually only 3 30 a.m so uh i
don't give a [ __ ]
uh what did you go to college for
mechanical engineering
seven mics a day yeah i do that
sometimes here uh seven mics a day is
[ __ ]
[ __ ] awesome man it's the way you're
supposed to do comedy just joke after
joke after joke you come up with a new
joke on monday by tuesday it's perfected
that's what uh bill burr said yes i'm in
my van it's called an nyc to live in a
van luckily i have a heater a heater
that heats up the van
so it's fun you know what's the best
site to find popular open mics in nya i
heard they have a facebook group indoor
outdoor mics but it used to be
freemikes.com
it's [ __ ] crazy man new york is like
[ __ ] crazy they got like paid mics
you got like different kind of mics
um
not posing
what is pausing on the mic
do a joke about underachieving about
johnny kim
johnny kim it's like such a specific
reference unless you've seen the meme
and please don't send it to me
uh i'm glad that you're thinking about
me and that you think that i look like
this other dude but uh it's like
non-stop people have been sending me
that [ __ ]
like
over and over again can you go back to
engineering in the future if you want
yeah i could definitely go back to
engineering in the future if i want
it's easy
engineering is the easiest thing ever
you just have to like
put everything into matlab or autocad
hans you would make a good trans woman
good cheekbones
i would need to do something about this
giant chin
this is a turn off
oh here we go
seven mike sounds crazy in a day
the dog plays b-ball lol
math
why would he not be able to go back yeah
i mean like i'm sure there's some
company that would hire me you know
maybe some people would be like no he's
not a
he hasn't sacrificed his whole life like
we have you need to be able to
uh dedicate all your time to this and if
you don't then you're not a real
whatever but
whatever you know like if i can do the
job you shouldn't
screen people for a job based on like
how brainwashed they are and how willing
they are to sacrifice their life for the
company in an ideal capitalist free
market
economy you should just pay people
because of the benefit that they can
provide your company but it's not about
that is it because it's never just a
[ __ ] mathematical transaction there's
a lot more that goes on to humans than
just benefit cost
ratio
calculations you're looking at them
you're like are you like me do you can i
hang with you do you live the same
lifestyle do you uh
can i emotionally trust you and
spiritually are we on the same page
there's a lot of that going on and if
you're not
with them on that specific wavelength
then a lot of people won't hire you
because it's not about whether you can
do the job or not we don't have an
economy that's just like
oh uh practical it's like oh you're
you're doing the thing that you're
supposed to hear some money or else
there'd be no cubicle workers that are
just wasting their life surfing reddit
all day
it's about uh
whatever
it's about uh compliance and whether you
can uh help your boss maintain their
delusion of whatever they think they're
doing in the world
uh
um
yeah i mean uh you do need to stay
involved and it's like a big deal but if
i can do the job then i should be able
to do it
um how do you expand your consciousness
talking to others doing drugs watching
crazy documentaries listening to
podcasts
on and on
all asians look high except the angry
eye ones
stop questioning authorities says
trapbox media well i'm sorry trapbox
media but i'm a free thinker and you
can't tell me what to do
i like jiro dreams of sushi i like
others i just can't think of any right
now if i see a list of documentaries i
can
documentaries
best
and i'll see which ones i've seen i
loved black whale or whatever
big fish or black fish
uh that was a good one um
i liked what else my optimist teacher
was good it's not my favorite what what
are my favorites
what are the classic documentaries
um
bowling for columbine i love that uh the
style of that
mike what a what's his name michael
whatever
the style he's like very opinionated and
you can see the world from his eyes and
he's like this is correct this is the
way the world should be and it's not
like that because these people are evil
and stupid and dumb
i like that i like that alex honnell
documentary
just because i was like
it was like an interesting thing i've
always been interested in uh
i've always been interested in rock
climbing i think it's very similar to
comedy it's like people just do it for
the love of the game
uh i saw tickled which i watched because
i was really into tickle i'm still
really into tickle porn i love watching
girls get tickled
uh but tickled it's uh interesting
because it's mostly dudes and
i had to watch dudes get tickled which i
was not that into
bloop
hopefully this i'm not revealing
anything crazy right now
um
american factory was great
i loved american factory because it's
like america is getting america by china
it's like china built a factory in
america and now they're treating their
workers like [ __ ] and they can't say
anything because they we treat our own
workers like [ __ ] so like
who are we to complain
oh you're gonna complain that china is
treating your workers like [ __ ] like
everyone's being treated like [ __ ]
restrepo i saw bits and pieces of it
uh amy was so good
uh
blackfish is what i was talking about
um
others others others other documentaries
yeah
so
those are my documentaries
for tonight
bowling for wuhan
i know that michael moore is very
controversial
um but i think he's right for the most
part
he did a podcast about the po pro
portland protests where he was like how
do we support you
we're doing i'm trying to bring a
spotlight to it but he's like so
uh he's so like controversial that it's
like sometimes he does more harm
but i think that if you hate him then
it's like well i don't want to turn
anyone off but like
that's your fault so it's like
you just got to do what you got to do
and michael moore is doing whatever he's
got to do
so
pokemon favorite probably the pikachu
i love pikachu so much
um
tell tony hinchcliffe that he sits down
like donald trump stands up i don't even
know what that means how can someone sit
down like someone else stands up
your neck is getting wrecked
yeah i know i need to fix my
fix my neck if you have stem cells
please
send it to me and i can inject it
um
[Music]
what is my favorite pokemon what haircut
do you get i get the self haircut i did
it myself and it's terrible i [ __ ]
hate it
but whatever
um
thanks for emailing me your stem cells
what's your favorite fast food
restaurant panda express
what's a bone setter that sounds scary
get a bone setter
i don't know what a bone setter is are
you talking about chiropractor joe rogan
hates chiropractors
and i hate him too do you have your
booster shot not yet
have you been to san diego
you should get dreadlocks i've been to
san diego
thanks man
it's actually
not that good
oh [ __ ] bone center is like cairo but
better dude i'll have to check it out
all right i think i'm gonna call it
thank you guys so much i love you